حضر الاتحاد الاوروبي من ان منطقه اليورو
ستدخل في حاله ركود خلال الشتاء بينما
رفعت بروكسيل توقعتها بشان معدلات التضخم
للعامين 2022 و 2023 على خلفيه ارتفاع
اسعار الطاقه وافادت المفوضيه الاوروبيه
بان زياده ضبابيه الوضع وارتفاع تكاليف
يتوقع ان يدخل منطقه اليورو ومعظمه بلدان
التكتل في حاله ركود في الفصل الاخير من
هذا العام
هذا الخبر سيكون له الكثير من التدعيات
هذه هي منطقه اليوم التي تحدثت عنها
المفوضيه الاوروبيه تسعه عشره دوله كما
تشاهدون كلها كلها بحسب المفوضيه ستواجه
انكماشا في اقتصاداتها لكن ما هو الانكماش
يحدث عندما تنخفض اسعار السلع بمعنى ان
القيمه الشرائيه للعمله تصبح اكبر يبدو
الامر جيدا في البدايه لكنه ليس كذلك ويعد
اسوا واختر من التدخل حيث ان هذا الانخفاض
باسعار السلع يترافقوا مع عدم رغبه
المستهلكين بالشراء فيتراجع الاستهلاك
سريعا تنخفض الجدوى بالنسبه للمستثمرين
والمنتجين فتتراجع اعمالهم ويبداون
بالتخلص من الموظفين فتزدادوا نسبه
البطاله
لا يتوقف الامر عند هذا الحد بل سرعان ما
تنخفض ايضا قيمه الاصول الماليه وتنخفض
كذلك ايرادات الدوله من الضرائب هذا حديث
اقتصادي ينصرف بطبيعه الحال لكن بالنسبه
للقاره الاوروبيه فهو امر اشكالي ومتشعب
على اكثر من صعيد المفوضيه الاوروبيه
افادت بان الوضع ازداد ضبابيه مع ارتفاع
التكاليف بسبب حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
فبات الناس اكثر حذرا واقل رغبه في
الاقبال على الشراء
وتوقعت ان يسجل معدل التضخم ثمانيه فاصل
5% هذا العام اي اعلى بنقطه من التوقعات
السابقه وقد واجهت الكتله اسعار اعلى
لاسيما اسعار الطاقه والغذاء خلال الاشهر
12 المقبله حيث ارتفعت تكاليف تكاليف
الطاقه بنسبه تقارب
42% بين ما زادت
اسعار المواد الغذائيه بالنسبه تجاوزت
ال13%